you were talking about selfies earlier
so we have an official blue-steel selfie
stick but you've got the biggest you've
got the biggest selfie stick in the
world with you apparently thank you nope
we do this is this house directly from
the what about how do these won't work
so this was at the premiere do you have
it yeah yeah so this was at the premiere
oh my god yeah no well it's not
telescoped out okay yeah I was gonna do
it you could you make it bigger Ben I
don't even know how I guess oh there you
go
here hold on - are we really gonna use
this huh yeah why not this yellow use
yes
yeah don't let's not no does it not come
out full otherwise we'll just met salt
piston that's a good room okay dude I
broke it wait you broke myself I did I
twisted when I should do you have a
camera I have a camera for this okay
well let me take the camera the cool
thing is no now so the whole thing would
be to maybe do it like facing the other
way so the studio audience
oh that's a nice idea okay okay okay so
on there no you gotta be awesome
payment is attained okay okay okay okay
so if you are you holding that I'm
holding I've okay okay so if you're
there it's my second time with the stick
no so god that looks very precarious
okay okay I like that
okay elgyn you're in shock the audience
see everybody's in there okay good bit
lower will get lted into Oh
it was good well okay okay
where's the little one selfie stick
thing very quickly I'm gonna do one here
we go quick okay quick quick on here it
says uh I don't know anyone we could
just ask someone else to take the pics
our powers really okay I too much should
we do it here he'll do this making you
reconsider your stance on pictures in
the world okay we go here we go here we
go here we go so oh I am taking a
picture here we go happening so we look
away look away look away and turn back
into it so three two one in and yay
aha yeah so food are really it's this is
more it's more it's not even the result
like what what your